à plus d'une demi heure de route de
montréal
saint jean sur richelieu est presque
devenu une banlieue sud de la métropole
en raison de l'étalement urbain la ville
attire sans cesse de nouveaux résidents
et c'est plus vrai que jamais en 2020
malgré la pandémie
le mardi
louis philippe gravel faisait le point
avec son agent immobilier sur la
difficulté de trouver une maison là-bas
il quitte son condo montréalais pour une
meilleure qualité de vie et pour avoir
plus d espace pour ses enfants
je raconte a contacté mon agent et j'ai
vu telle maison on peut s'organiser
invisible ont regagné on se parlait
mercredi on organise une visite le
vendredi par le temps qu'on va voir la
maison il m'annonce que déjà quatre cinq
six des x 8 rohff d'achat déjà déposé
donc ça a créé beaucoup de surenchères
au niveau des maisons saint jean est en
train de devenir un point chaud de
l'immobilier dans la région cette année
cédric le bo a conclu une cinquantaine
de transactions de plus qu'à pareille
date en 2019
on est passé d'un prix moyen de 290 1000
$ pour une maison unifamiliale à 340,7
années fac ci celle du rau c'est la
grosse différence de la valeur la
possibilité je suis très surpris de voir
un nouveau des prix g je pensais pas que
les maisons talent aussi cher qu elle
soit à saint jean sur richelieu le cas
de saint jean est loin d'être unique en
juillet 2020 dans le grand montréal les
maisons unifamiliales se sont vendus 18
% plus cher qu'en juillet 2019
les copropriétés elle 12 % plus cher
vous savez ceux ci cette récession si
c'est la première de l'histoire
canadienne ou une récession et constater
sans entraîner une chute du prix des
maisons
bien des experts croyaient que le
coronavirus frapperait plus durement le
marché de l'immobilier
le nombre de transactions a bel et bien
diminué de 7% cette année dans la région
sur l'île de montréal seulement de 15%
mais le rattrapage se fait rapidement
depuis la fin du confinement les maisons
à vendre ne le reste pas longtemps on a
quand même une 9 qui est très faible
dans toute la région de montréal et donc
ça fait en sorte qu'on se retrouve
malgré tout avec des marchés très serré
est ce ça va faire en sorte qu'on une
pression assez forte sur les prix pour
une bonne partie de la population la
capacité de travailler à distance a
permis aux gens de conserver leurs
revenus donc de ne pas être obligé de
vendre leur propriété dans un contexte
peut-être un conjoint perdait son emploi
ce télétravail que plusieurs entreprises
ont découvert devrait à moyen terme
accentué l'intérêt pour les couronnes de
montréal
si saint jean a déjà la cote au sud
certaines villes au nord comme mirabel
ou terrebonne continue d'attirer elle
aussi le marché de la rive nord reste le
plus chaud les maisons unifamiliales
s'ils sont vendus 19 % plus cher en
juillet par rapport à juillet 2010 9
prix médian 351 mille dollars
quant à l'île de montréal elle reste
toujours très populaire sur l'île de
montréal ça fait longtemps que la
demande est forte
un peu partout c'est sûr que ça
commençait à se concentrer surtout dans
les quartiers centraux ceux qui sont
autour du centre-ville
maintenant où on en est si une demande
qui forte de manière généralisée à
travers les lots complets l'automne nous
dira si le rattrapage d'un printemps
marqué par le confinement continuera de
plus belle sur les marchés et les
experts restent prudents la deuxième
vague possible du virus et la fin de
plusieurs mesures dead comme le report
des paiements hypothécaires pourrait
frapper de plein fouet l'immobilier ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal